you've accomplished a lot in this first
lesson starting with nothing more than
Android studio and hope you've created
your first project built and deployed it
to virtual and actual devices and even
created a simple list based UI that's
populated using an adapter you also
learned a little about what makes mobile
and Android in particular a different
environment to develop for them desktop
web and server we've only just gotten
started the app we've got so far is
using static mock data so join us in
lesson two to learn how to hook it up to
real weather data but before that take a
moment to cleanse your palate with a
brief interlude exploring the history
and evolution of the Android ecosystem